hi I'm Chet Haase an engineer on the
Android team at Google
recently at Google i/o 2013 we gave a
talk called a moving experience which
was about various animation techniques
and capabilities the Android platform
and a lot of these techniques centered
around some of the principles of
animation that early cartoon animators
came up with and I want to talk about a
couple of those briefly today one is
anticipation and the other is over
shooting or follow-through and these
techniques along with a host of other
techniques are used to help the users in
their case the viewers of these cartoons
very quickly understand what was going
on in the screen they had very few
frames to work with sometimes 24 frames
a second or actually more like 12 frames
a second maybe even eight six or eight
frames a second so there wasn't a lot of
time in any particular second to
understand the action I mean the actions
would would happen really quickly and
they needed the users to be locked onto
with the action in the cartoon
constantly because if they missed it it
was gone and they didn't have time to
rewind and see what had happened so
instead they gave as many indications
and and aids to the user as possible to
the viewer as possible so that they
could really clue into what was going on
but we have the same problems to some
extent in user interfaces where you
really need the users to understand
what's going on in your application if
many confusing things are happening if
you're replacing entire screens with
entire other screens
if the workflow is really complicated as
you go from activity to activity or
screen to screen or viewed a few then
how is the user supposed to not get lost
in your application what you really want
them to do is complete be completely
locked into the flow that you imagine
for your application so that they
understand that flow as well as you did
when you wrote that incredibly complex
UI well if you can use some of the
techniques that they came up with
cartoons then maybe you can help the
users understand the interactions that
they're having with your application as
well and help them understand and be
more productive with your application
the same time so it's sometimes a little
bit of a stretch between these cartoony
effects and maybe the effects that
you're looking for in your application
but it is possible to sort of connect
these dots and say okay given this
technique what they were going for how
could we actually apply that technique
if maybe not make it quite as cartoony
in the business context anyway let's see
the actual demo so we have a demo here
called live button if you click the
button the button interacts so there's a
couple of different interesting elements
to this one is the anticipation where
when you click on the button it gets
smaller and when you release the button
it doesn't just return to its previous
state but it overshoots that and swings
back so this is the anticipation as it
presses in and then it's the overshoot
as it actually comes back not just to
its original position that actually
passed it there's some interesting
aspects to this one is that it makes the
objects feel more organic and natural
and it also makes them more engaging in
general I saw techniques specifically
like this on a game console years ago
and whether the buttons were pressed in
when you clicked on them or actually
popped out when you clicked on them
actually that interaction didn't matter
what I noticed was that the buttons
themselves were much more engaging and
this was really important in the game
context where you really want the whole
experience to be more fun and engaging
to begin with and it helps the user feel
like they're really interacting with the
machine in the game instead of just
clicking buttons in a user interface so
the way to get these effects is very
simple we'll see some more complex
applications these techniques and other
demos but in this particular application
it's very simple I'm not actually
handling click events here all I'm doing
is tracking up-and-down events and then
making the button look differently I'm
letting the superclass actually track
track the the clicks and the motion
events because I don't care about that
all I care about is make the button
smaller and make the button larger to
overshoot so we make it smaller by
grabbing a view property animator on the
button so we say click my button dot
animates we set the interpolator to this
decelerate err which is decel
interpolator decelerate interpolator
that we defined above this means that
we're going to start fast when they
click on it and
slow down toward the end and it's
important to start fast because you
don't want them to hit the button and
then get this sluggish feeling as it
accelerates into an animation instead
you want it to start really quickly and
possibly slow down at the ends but the
the main element you want is actually to
you wanted to start really quickly and
you want it to be a very short duration
as well so we use a decelerate er here
and notice that I actually change the
duration of the view property animator
to 200 instead of its default 300
because I wanted the animation to be
very quick so we set the decelerate er
and then we simply scaled the button so
we're going to animate that scale make
the button smaller as the user presses
on it and then when they release we're
just going to do the same thing in
Reverse we're going to set scale X and
scale Y animate those back to one except
instead of just animating the back to
where they started we're going to use
this overshoot interpolator that we
defined above so it'll actually animate
past one and then back to sort of give
that organic feeling of actually
bouncing back out then finally settling
into its final position anticipation and
overshoot or follow-through very
important elements of cartoon animation
applicable to some cases of user
interfaces if you want the interface to
be more indicative to the user of
actually what's happening in the flow or
is simply more engaging and playful and
organic Thanks